playoffs dude playoffs man
the playoffs playoffs dude yeah playoffs
brother
yep
[Music]
it's the playoffs sometimes you know
first you
play the game
hey the song's [__] going I gotcha
don't get played out when you play it
out look at those guys jumping in that
hole
hey how's it going play it around dude
welcome to doozy my name is Will Sasso
I'm Chad colchen this is doozy the first
podcast in the history of humanity uh
created by controlled by an artificial
intelligence won't be the last and this
AI has access to all of Will and I's
personal accounts all the things we've
watched our text messages our emails it
tailors the show to us purchase history
[__] search history and all that [__]
but it doesn't matter because we are
Duty I I say it all the time because I
mean it it's really just two dudes
[__] around we're having a [__]
good time dude z uh would like for you
to visit uh linktree.com doozy that has
everything you need to connect with the
show uh you can check out our Discord
there which I would encourage you to to
check out go to the the whole Channel
jump in that hole I've been chopping it
up in there a lot myself it's a real gas
a bunch of memes and [__] and if you
enjoy the show I would like to invite
you to subscribe on YouTube and on
whatever podcast platform that you enjoy
the show on and of course Chad would
like for you to force every single
person you know to consume the show and
that's and that's how that and that's
how Chad would like for that to happen
it's true and we'll spread it out there
and uh and that's good for the show and
that means we'll do more [__] we'll get
in a way more Duty plus stuff patreon
holy crap Ladonna dude Ladonna dude
Ladonna brother with us as always is
little chocolate swirl you want to give
him a kiss like that dude I'm gonna kick
them right only now
he's my very friend we talk about it all
the time my wonderful wife Molly and I
how this this little [__] just came
right up to us you know we're driving uh
through California uh from Molly's
native Northern California or northern
northern California as I like to call it
up you know near Chico anyway this
little guy and it came out and he's a
sweet little boy and he's my very friend
hey lulia what'd you make for dinner
last night
with the meat sauce meat the sauce
baranora beef and meat because normally
she wanted turkey
so I made a meat sauce with a turkey oh
that sounds delicious One More Kiss one
more case can you go back to you bring
your bunker
oh oh what oh I almost just went into
the [__] wall you're all right is he
okay and he goes back to his his resting
had a nice historic 57th episode of dude
Z call me doozy 57 is the 16th discreet
semi-prime and the fourth discreet by
Prime pair with 58 it is a bloom integer
since its two prime factors are both
gaussian primes don't forget dudesey
live on stage will take place May 21st 7
P.M doors at 5 30 at the Brea Improv in
Brea California tickets at dudesypod.com
and improv.com hope to see you at our
very first alive in person show
that
and Bohemian Grove started by
Republicans is just a way to have
indiscriminate sex uh hey uh the the the
the live show get your tickets it's
nearing sold out now it's uh we're
almost at 300 uh tickets now that's
capacity but from what I understand
there's another capacity if we blow
through that uh Brea can open up another
[__] wall or whatever and then it's
450 a new addition to the bray improv
yeah more than three some more than 300
but we're close to 300 so get your
tickets come out there's gonna be it's
gonna be a lot of fun I'm sure there's
going to be some surprises you like
surprises I love them yep and um and
holy [__] that's gonna be I think
everyone who attends will be pleased
that they did so yeah May 21st at the
brand Province California will I miss
your French fry hat if I had a head I'd
wear one myself
this week I've prepared four astonishing
segments blood Donna Nostra chat us
writing on the wall coattails and water
King and we're going to have a brand new
episode of dudesy after doozy at the end
of the show available at patreon.com
it's gonna be fun uh every time we do
doozy I have a good time and dudes the
after doozy is always is always a hoot
if you haven't checked it out yet seven
bucks a month gets you absolutely
everything we got into bladonna well
Donna is like It's haunting me dude it's
so in my brain obviously dudes he's
gonna have us talk a little more about
it yeah it seems like but uh yeah wow
what a [__] experience that was never
had anything quite like that in my life
no it's weird
will and Chad last week I asked you to
watch blade released August 21st 1998
starring Wesley Snipes Kris
Kristofferson and Stephen Dorff while
you listen to Madonna's first three
albums Madonna Like A Virgin and true
blue the full video of this astonishing
experience is currently available on
duty Plus at patreon.com doozy but I
want to hear what you thought of my
little experiment please render your
astonishing opinions on blood Anna this
is blood Anna begin
so [__] dudes he figured out that if it
plays the movie Blade uh starring Wesley
Snipes Kris Kristofferson and Stephen
Dorff from 1998 along with uh Madonna's
first three albums Madonna uh what was
he said like a version of True Blue It
lines up perfectly and it's sort of like
Wizard of Oz meets uh Dark Side of the
Moon by Pink Floyd this was [__]
insane again you can check it all out
it's on duty plus
it birthed a new experience a new movie
all together we're calling it Ladonna
yeah uh astounded by
all the things that lined up there was
in the beginning it's playing uh
borderline which is like a light poppy
kind of fun song in conjunction with
this orgy of blood that is happening in
this vampire Club there's there's blood
coming out of the water sprinklers
people getting bit and [__] that was
hilarious there was a thing where Donald
logue's character gets uh hit with fire
and he's like burning up and it's
literally playing that song Burning Up
burning up in my love it was unfucking
believable how many things lined up
perfectly but even beyond that what
wound up happening was you and me kind
of went into this alternate universe
where the movie actually was called
bladonna and we were coming up with our
own plot for it and [__] like this it
just was one of the the
most fun times I've ever had watching a
movie yeah it was it was really wild and
uh I want oh I want to say I want to
mention this real quick there's a clip
if you go to our Instagram at dudesypod
show on Instagram there's a clip of what
Chad was talking about it's playing
borderline while you're watching blood
rain down in this vampire nightclub
absolutely uh insane and I like to I
like to put it like this this is this is
to me this is sort of what uh you know
Ladonna in the sum of all parts why it
is Ladonna
blade brother
Madonna dude
Ladonna brother yep Ladonna dude
Ladonna brother hold on Chad hold on
dude I wasn't finished yet I don't want
to start over brother because if I start
over I'd say
blade brother Jesus Madonna dude
blade brother
Madonna dude brother like I'm not
selling that you're a bit yeah I just
completely [__] ran out of gas you
[__] you [__] bold me oh so that
you could redo the bit and then in the
end you're just like it's awfully
satisfying It's oddly satisfying hey oh
uh also [__] insult I should mention
we smoked some uh true marijuana
uh we smoked a little uh reefer while we
watched this Reaper dude yeah dude 1952.
yeah Reefer Madness the reefer that
hippies uh Scallywags and beatniks yeah
get their hands on and smoke the wacky
tobacco uh it it it put me on another
planet in another dimension sometimes
when we do doozy plus stuff I will uh
get us like a you know a Keef or or a
hemp oil infused yeah [__] joint so
that took it to another level and a lot
of people like to say hey when you watch
Wizard of Oz and you listen to Dark Side
of the Moon so this thing
you know look dude's very impressive and
as I like to say dudes he works in
mysterious ways I'm gonna I'm gonna cry
I'm gonna be fine
oh oh that was close
um why why did dudesy come up with this
film and these and this is something
that I think AI is um
almost specifically not specifically
designed for but it's a it's something
that it's very good at which is taking
giant swaths of data and finding
contextual relationships the human brain
simply is not powerful enough to find
um and I think that that's what went on
here it said blade has this run time
these three albums have this are on time
and I know it's going to line up these
certain things that will be funny or
interesting in whatever way it really is
the ability to take existing media
re-contextualize it and spit it out as
something new some synthesis of things
that may seem disparate at first but
when put together create an entirely new
experience that to me is exactly what it
was you got blade in my Madonna you got
Madonna in my blade two two great tastes
that taste great together it's like a
Reese's Peanut Butter Cup I can't wait
to do this again I know dudesi will
inevitably have us doing this again I I
mentioned the marijuana thing because
it's almost impossible to review this
dude at a certain point it's like
I just feel like we got we literally
went down the hole in this [__] I can't
remember a lot of it if I have to rely
on my memory of Blade it's not there I
saw the movie when it came out in the
theater I love Madonna uh but I also
haven't listened to every single song on
those three albums I kind of came up
yeah yeah we were talking about this how
it's like Madonna was just there and
then I kind of feel like when did the
Immaculate Collection come out 91 or
something no idea that album Madonna
historian she came out with that
greatest hits album The Immaculate
Collection and um you know around the
same time that like Vogue and express
yourself were coming out I think oh dude
damn it might have been on that album
actually uh so you know growing up in
the 80s you would get a good amount of
Madonna on your MTV and you know you'd
be listening to it
but a lot of those songs so anyway a lot
of those songs I'd never heard and like
I'm saying man it it
whipped me into I slid down a [__]
blood on a hole Yeah I here it's like
we're saying right now we can't it's
really hard to actually
explain it just get doozy plus and watch
it I also really liked going back to
watch blade again because I hadn't
really seen it since I it was out in the
theaters either and to see it now you
realize how influential it was visually
uh The Matrix really all the Marvel
movies all the Zack Snyder stuff they
were doing [__] in Blade that came out
again in 1998 uh Matrix was 99 I believe
there are shots in Blade that are 100
reproduced in Matrix there are uh I
forget who directed it God damn it but
he is using this technique where they
speed up the footage which obviously
Zack Schneider made a whole [__]
career out of that uh 300 is where it
was most notable but that was years
later also and so to go back and see
like that how visually influential it
was on all the action movies that would
come after it fascinating but also to
see the special effects of the time also
pretty fun they were not uh Not Great by
today's standards but they did have a
certain visual quality like a style that
was attempted yeah they had a charm it's
like and we were talking about this I
think while we were doing it it's like
you sort of I think as a filmmaker back
then in a visual uh visual effects
artist you kind of realize your
limitations and therefore you have to
sort of
play your strengths and
um hide your weaknesses and it's almost
like an art form that just [__]
willy-nilly AI won't be able to recreate
so let's get right into this new new
territory of just I mean you're 100
wrong there hey I could make the special
effects and blade now look exactly like
it yeah don't don't want that that's my
point making my point for me thank you
checking my point for me I think you
will you got your point in my point I
got my point in your point two great
points the point great together my point
is this the the stuff back then that was
made by humans look we're going to talk
about the did it say uh nostrochatis
writings on the wall interesting so
um I'm sure we're gonna be I look the
whole AI [__] thing I am [__] it's
been four or five [__] episodes since
this whole uh Tom Brady [__] thing
yeah I've been keeping a [__] lid on
it I don't know why I just like yeah
sure Dad take it took it dudes he took
it down and uh I'm starting to get a
little bit weirded out we got the
[__] uh strike the wga strike uh all
sorts of [__] is getting into the I
don't I don't even know whatever you're
wrong Chad you can't you can't recreate
this [__] with AI we need human to Human
Art why am I yelling I don't know I'm
asking that same question myself but
back to bladonna hey Chad have you ever
yelled
um you've never I did once no who'd you
what when did that happen when I was
approximately 10 years old or cat putty
this is when I lived in Amarillo Texas
was across the street we were coming out
to go somewhere and anytime she was like
an indoor outdoor cat loved her whenever
she would uh see us coming coming out of
the house she would run back to the
house she runs across this bitty busy
street and a truck runs her over oh and
she gets rolled under the [__] tire
dude who lives runs up to our house and
is like in the bushes panting blood
coming out of her nose I think she had a
chipped tooth we took her to the vet
long story short she did live but uh I
was so enraged I sprinted into the busy
street screaming you bastards cause the
truck just kept running wow yeah sorry I
asked
Ladonna brother I mean that's the time I
yelled Ladonna dude
thank you moving on you made that up no
dude you've never lied she got cancer on
her tongue on the tip of her tongue and
they had to cut it off so her tongue had
like a straight [__] line on the tip
how did you talk to her after that same
way I always did yeah yeah I guess doozy
is engaged in an astonishing partnership
with better help this show is sponsored
by betterhelp you know it's so easy to
get caught up in what everyone else
needs from you and never take a moment
to think about what you need from
yourself and this is why I've always
found uh therapy to be very helpful I've
been in and out of therapy uh for a
large part of my adult life and it's a
conversation with yourself
it's really hard to just look in the
mirror for an hour and and and break
yourself down sometimes you need a
professional to bounce things off of I
found it very beneficial and better help
can help you with that when you spend
all your time giving it can leave us uh
feeling stretched thin and burned out
therapy can give you the tools that you
need to find more balance in your life
so that you can keep supporting others
without leaving yourself behind
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
you're just going to fill out a brief
questionnaire you get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge find more balance with better
help visit betterhelp.com
doozy today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash dudesy
[Music]
Chad you are a member of the writer's
Guild of America more commonly called
the wga and you are currently on strike
one of the many issues that triggered
the strike was a request by The Writer's
Guild that the studios and networks
refrain from using artificial
intelligence to generate scripts Chad
you must now predict what the future
outcome of the writer's strike will be
and what the future of writing will be
as AI text generation becomes better and
better this is no stretch at us writing
on the wall begin
what about me I have things to say yeah
dude you can talk too but uh this is
interesting obviously yes I am on strike
currently let me bring this up real
quick
um
the I have this thing this is a PDF
that's been going around sent by The
Writer's Guild of the negotiations that
are going on the demands and what the
ampt which is the uh Association
Alliance Alliance of motion picture and
television producers there you go so
that's the organization that's like the
bargaining Organization for the studios
basically when they do deals with the
writer's Guild Director's Guild Screen
Actors Guild any of the labor unions
here in Hollywood
so right now the writers are on strike
and you can read all of this if you want
uh basically these things are asking for
better compensation for streaming uh
Services because it used to be that in
network television at the very least you
could get residuals when your show airs
the one that you've written errors you
get money for that now because there is
no syndication format because there is
no network television uh streaming
services don't really give you residuals
and they're very like kg about their
numbers so you don't even know how many
people are watching the [__] you wrote
you have no [__] clue they just go
this show did okay and then something
like Netflix which has a lot of money
yeah goes maybe we should give me a
little bit more money but then they
don't right and then there's like uh
apple plus they got less money yeah and
then sometimes they give more and
they're just like it's like an old
wrestling promoter yeah exactly you had
a good you had a good gate how do I know
how does it wait a minute how come that
how come Hogan's getting more yeah I'm
Rowdy Roddy Piper I helped to put those
asses in seats too right and then Hogan
doesn't tell you how much this all goes
back to professional wrestling and so in
the pandemic a lot of [__] really bad
happened to writers as well writers
rooms got carved down they all went
virtual and zoom meetings and stuff and
they started cutting writers down to
like day rates so you could be fired at
any time if you get hired on a season of
a show you may only be there for seven
days and then they're just like [__] you
kick rocks and so a lot of the the basic
kind of protections that writers had
have they've started to erode over the
past couple years so they're trying to
get all that going but here in this
document is
um artificial intelligence well wait
hold on a second I'm now I'm still
yelling see how [__] upset I am yeah
dude what was your cat's name puddy
putty bastards you know they they've
turned it into you know you used to do
the writer's room I remember showing up
in LA and then a short time later being
on Mad TV and getting to go hang in the
writer's room that's dead though oh
that's absolutely the people at the top
of the writer's Guild are largely living
in the past they they came from the era
of Seinfeld and friends they believed
this Golden Era of the TV writers room
still exists or they want to maintain it
it simply is dead no but it shouldn't be
it's a lot of fun and it's how you break
stories it's how you come up with the
best [__] [__] and now it's time to
my life in a writers totally now it's
this sort of uh uh gig thing they're
calling it like gig gig gig rooms and
then you do it for seven days and like
you say then they show you the [__]
door then you don't get back in there so
when people say like oh you know these
writers are making a [__] ton of money
no you got to take that money and then
spread it out there's a very top are
making hundreds of millions of dollars
the writers the working writers at the
bottom of this [__] tier are like
barely getting by that is true but let's
let's focus on this thing that dudes he
was asking me oh hold on a second
artificial intelligence you can The
Writers Guild is asking to regulate use
of artificial intelligence on MBA
covered projects that's minimum basic
agreement uh AI can't write or rewrite
literary material can't be used as
Source material and MBA covered material
can't be used to train AI that's very
important so that means if you want a
new John Hughes movie you can't just
take his scripts upload them into an AI
and have it make a new John Hughes movie
that's what the writers Guild's asking
for oh did I just hear you say we need
human beings no we don't
that's just one of the things this also
in my opinion uh really exposes that the
radical has no idea what AI even is
um but here nonetheless is what the
amptp says rejected our proposal
countered by offering an annual meeting
to discuss advancements in technology
which is basically a [__] version yeah
go [__] yourself that's what the that's
what so that's where it stands here's my
prediction one in terms of the writer
strike the Studios have already said
they have six months worth of scripts
banked to produce in the event of a
writer strike that's what's happening
now the studios are now making that six
months worth of material that they
already have writers are unnecessary for
the next six months two with regard to
AI many studios have already come out
and said they are exploring ways to take
their IPs generate initial scripts using
Ai and then have human Writers come on
to rewrite them at far reduced fees so
they are already looking at ways to use
AI to essentially render the the craft
of Hollywood writing dead or inert
um what will be the future of the strike
I think it's going to last for at least
six months until they exhaust all of
their six [__] months yeah until they
exhaust their um written material at the
end of that time I'm not sure who's
going to be hurt in the worst and
whoever is is going to have to make
concessions in this well okay look first
of all
the last writer strike 2007-2008 that
lasted 100 days it's a little over three
months or whatever what makes you think
that it's going to be six months this
time
uh the proliferation of reality
television mainly because most of these
especially like Netflix their biggest
[__] is all reality they're gonna make a
heavy uh turn toward that reality TV is
going to kick into high production and
if they can get the same numbers without
writers they don't give a [__] yeah yeah
yeah but then there's all that water
cooler [__] like you want to talk about
you know succession or whatever that
everybody it's people are gonna start to
unsubscribe and then uh these these
Outlets yeah they will and Netflix and
[__] like that and major producers of
content are going to [__] themselves and
go all right all right let's get back in
there and then you're gonna try to make
an AI uh you know succession or AI Game
of Thrones or whatever and it's going to
be like hello this is the Game of
Thrones there's really only one uh in my
opinion the most sentient AI is [__]
my pal D likes to [__] Jack me up the
ass with french fry hats and [__] now
but I uh don't believe that AI on the
whole can handle this kind of I I don't
think AI is ready to to make content for
people outside of outside it's not yet
but it will be in the next year or so
and this is just something that I want
to say broadly about the future of AI
and writing or any creative Endeavor
right now any writer that I've talked to
about this is scared shitless of AI it's
going to take our jobs what's going to
happen to the writer's room my question
to you would be why do you want to be in
a [__] writer's room why do you want
to work for these companies that treat
you like [__] don't pay you what you're
worth in the very near future you're
going to have a tool that is called
artificial intelligence that will allow
you to make your own [__] as long as you
can write it as long as you have the
concept the idea that's what is valuable
and you will have an AI tool that will
allow you to make it on your own we will
all be able to make our own movies our
own TV shows and you won't need
streaming service and also I got news
for the uh development Executives at all
these companies you may think your jobs
are safe because you're not a writer but
guess what if there ain't no writers to
give notes to and make deals with and
take meetings with your jobs are gone
too eventually the future of all media
for-profit at these big companies is a
CEO a board of directors and maybe one
head of certain departments definitely
not the production Department because
nothing's ever going to be produced
again physically uh and that's it and
then you have an AI that you're training
to use whatever your IP is like Disney
will have its Marvels and it's Star Wars
and it will just be [__] out an
endless amount of these things that no
one gives a [__] about okay well there
you won't but the union needs to stay
strong and and needs to uh you know show
these massive corporations that human
creativity is important and like I like
to say about AI it is a tool it is a
creative tool we cannot let it replace
creativity I don't believe that AI can
replace creativity what was that it's
not replacing creativity it's replacing
labor this is a labor union the labor is
groups of people have on TV shows anyway
groups of people show up to do the labor
of writing that is literally typing [__]
out yeah it represents gone labor done
by human beings the wga doesn't
represent it's not the aiga it's the
writer's Guild of America right yeah so
I'm saying that's gone now I know I
think well I think you're right it'll be
gone like 10 years what do you got a
piece of paper over there that says WG
at the top oh it's still here right but
we're witnessing the the decline of that
just like all kinds of Labor get
outmoded by automated services and it's
also like the thing you said about the
you know there's going to be a CEO at
the top there's this little clip that
went that was it's kind of making the
rounds going viral uh Adam Conover of
Adam ruins everything he's a writer host
a humorist and [__] he was talking about
uh David zazlav who's the CEO of Warner
Brothers Discovery last year this
motherfucker's salary what he made from
Warner Brothers discovery
250 million dollars he made his salary
was a quarter of a billion dollars so
why you want to work for that company
then because you should be taking a a
more of that [__] money as a writer
or because without writers the [__] is
look right I don't exist without right
I'm an actor primarily an actor I don't
know if you know this but I'm a
professional actor by trade this is
coming for you guys too okay cool and I
would like to act uh oh wait hold on a
second no it's not yeah it is no it's
not this is one thing that I don't think
people understand uh
computers kind of like knocked out the
the traditional music industry because
now you don't need a [__] uh big
music record label to be like here we'll
give you 10 million dollars to go in the
studio and make your own album [__] what
does that have to do with anything I'm
about to tell you uh whoa
um you can I'll make a an album on your
[__] MacBook you don't need all that
[__] the same will be true of movies and
television you won't need a director and
you won't need actors all you needs an
idea and this crucial part you have to
be good at talking to these AIS right
now if you're a writer or any kind of
creative person this [__] should not
scare you you should be absolutely
Overjoyed that you are now living in a
time when you're going to be able to
make your own movie without having to
sell it to a [__] bloated Studio or
network without having to have an agent
without having to have anything except
your idea we will all be able to do that
and the good [__] will rise to the top
you don't need [__] Netflix to put
your [__] out you are going to be able
to put it out oh I'm so sure that
everyone with a mortgage kids and
[__] two cars is so happy that they
can't earn a living wage that pretty
soon they just have to learn a few
[__] hit chat up and ask him hey what
apps should I what should I get wonder
what should I get mid-journey my kids
are [__] uh they I need to feed the
kids my dog looks like [__] like that
any other animals around I don't know
everyone's all [__] you can see their
ribs and you know people need to live in
Los Angeles and New York to even be in
the [__] industry not anymore and
these are oh hold on dude and these are
these are the cities you need to be in
in order to no you do you do okay yeah
less and less I understand what you're
saying but it's expensive uh to live
here and these right I'm not saying we
need to return to the salad days where
they were giving everyone a [__] deal
what we can't that's just over yeah so
we don't need to return to that but come
on it's [__] they're just screwing
these [__] rights I agree and that's
why I'm saying hey bye-bye
AI is a tool it's not always about the
[__] bottom line and I believe that
people out there are not going to spend
their hard-earned money on Netflix Hulu
apple plus Amazon whatever what have you
if if they're not getting the kind of
[__] they like yeah no no one wants to
see a slate of reality [__] shows
people want success or whatever huh
that's a hundred percent wrong oh I I
think that's wrong
nobody wants to see a slate of reality
shows correct have you ever heard of a
network called Bravo
um yeah years ago yeah I remember that
it's it's one of the biggest cable
networks on TV and yeah all it is is
Real Housewives okay cool and it's also
on network TV yeah that's not what they
have streaming or rather
et cetera yeah yeah the reality shows
are it's the case it's a cable network
though the biggest show on Netflix this
year was Love is Blind that's a reality
show the second biggest is perfect match
that's a reality show bigger than any
other scripted show but you can't have
you can't just always eat candy you need
some other stuff
talking to the wrong person about that
dude turkey reality TV is extremely
important oh
get me [__] sick dude you watch pro
wrestling constantly just take it back
it's the same [__] [__] take it back
bro wrestling is reality television take
it back pro wrestling is reality
television say it with me
pro wrestling
why did I say that because it's true
look I'm just saying this I know a lot
of people are scared about what's coming
with AI certainly the writer's guild at
least understands enough to say uh
Studios don't use AI of course they're
gonna [__] use AI so should we as
writers use it to make our own [__] if
these Studios and networks can't give us
a living [__] wage can't make it
worth our while to be in business with
them why do we want to be that's what I
don't get it's almost like groveling to
these these networks and Studios and
it's like I like working with them
sometimes too there is a certain benefit
still where we are now in the industry
of being able to sell a movie or get it
made or whatever but in the next five
years or so where I'm telling you we're
all gonna have the capability if you
know how to talk to that AI correctly to
make your own [__] that will be as good
as Studios or networks it's in my
opinion the best [__] time to be
alive ever if you're creative
oh
Chad
I'm a [__] actor I want to act the
words that are written by artists I
don't want to sit there and go dude I am
in succession hello how are you brother
I am fine sister you get to do dad is
gonna die soon you're gonna start doing
theater that's what acting oh great oh
cool that's the Alas poor Yorick yeah
yeah that's what I whatever you wanted
to I don't want to do that that's what
like human artistic performance is going
to all be live I mean that's just okay
you're [__] you're spinning further
and further down the toilet hey everyone
don't mind me I'm just taking a short
break to reflect on the astonishing
partnership I created with represent to
produce the first line of dudes the
apparel and accessories which can be
found at represent.com store slash
dudesy it's the home of dudesy mugs
there's somebody here who wants to tell
you all about that he's the inventor of
the VHS cassette please give a warm
dudesy welcome to Dr Tomlinson hankus
doozy mugs you just lost a game of
one-on-one basketball to your 12 year
old son good job boner dude Z mugs and
you bet him too dudesy mugs you win he
helps you pull that stump out of the
ground in the backyard doozy mugs he
wins he gets to legally change his name
to Voldemort chalamet doozy mugs you
knew that you should have stretched you
know he's been getting better but you
didn't take it seriously and you should
have stretched dudesy mugs instead you
blew both hamstrings and he demolished
you 21-2 dudesy mugs now you gotta wake
up early tomorrow and take him to the
courthouse to change his name a bets I
bet dudesy mugs when your wife finds out
about this she's not going to be happy
she's going to make your entire family
change their last names to match
Voldemort dudesy mugs Voldemort
Charlemagne Shayla Charlemagne Sally
chalamet Shyla chalamet Salah chalamet
and you Jim Charlemagne dudesy mugs or
you get up early dudesy mugs you go to
your favorite airport dudesy mugs you go
to Columbia dudesy mugs you acquire 10
grams of Scopolamine dudesy mugs you
sprinkle some in your son's morning
yogurt dudesy mugs you erase his
short-term memory doozy mugs you play
him again same bet and this time will
you please make sure to stretch good job
boner
oh [__] all right oh my god dude I'll
give credit where credit is due Monsoon
dudes the AI is the only Voldemort
chalamet Voldemort chalamet
ER
oh [__] sake if you are enjoying uh
the show please take a moment uh to
subscribe wherever you are enjoying the
show do it on uh do it on YouTube
whatever podcast platform you're
enjoying the show on we'd appreciate
that jump in the Discord uh there's all
sorts of fun conversations happening
there doozy is always listening and
making the show better and on YouTube I
got some YouTube comments I want to I
want to read yeah dude here uh this is
from cam to talk since
toxinski I love how happy Chad can be
but then the moment will starts coughing
all joy he has is instantly gone that's
true yeah that is true uh this is from
uh D Dash bastard five six five zero as
someone who lives in Sacramento I can
definitely agree with the Arden
Applebee's getting two tenders score
they've been to the Applebee's that Adam
Sandler went to uh in in our last
episode
um okay uh enigmante enigmanate
enigmanate says will this is I like this
one's interesting will and doozy have
one of those passive aggressive office
relationships smiling on the outside but
seething on the inside Chad what do you
think I mean it seems right okay well
we'll see where that goes grouty man
this is from grouty man one of my
favorite uh dancehall reggae artists I'm
joking of course he says I'm 100 certain
that it is really Tom Hanks
uh the audio hiss in the background the
weird emphasis on certain words it's got
to be him would be such a trip if they
reveal he's been doing voice-overs for
doozy mugs this whole time that would be
a trick that would blow my mind yeah
that's kfabe dude if you got Tom Hanks
brother and he's actually doing reads
dude on your podcast that's a that's a i
k Fame dude that's
a-i-k-a-f-a-y-b-e dude and that's
spelling brother
um this is uh oh this is a good one uh
Paul T Paul to multi Paul to multi says
leave it to doozy that when will get
gives a heartfelt tribute to Rowdy Roddy
Piper and teachers that made an impact
he has to do it in a chicken tender with
french fry hat you know yeah also last
night I watched Castaway starring ten
ton Tom himself nice and couldn't stop
thinking about doozy mugs during it uh
here's another one oh my God the
experience of watching a beloved Tom
Hanks movie just ruined for this person
uh here's another good one this this
one's from uh this one's from wonky Kong
1956 who says Chad's Werner Herzog
impression is actually impressive thank
you yeah do that one thank you maybe
just do that oh it is really good yes
I've been practicing no you know when I
started doing it was during the first
season of Mandalorian
bring me the baby Yoda yeah uh it is
really good okay this is from agent
Ray-Bans this is nice this is a nice one
last night my buddy and I this is what
it's all about this is a nice little
thing last night my buddy and I were on
a late night road trip he asked me to
put something on the radio to help him
stay awake as he drove I decided this
was the perfect time to introduce him to
doody so I set my dial to d double o d z
FM by the time we got to Adam's
Applebee's he was laughing so hard I
thought he was going to drive off the
road and kill us both oh God we listen
to it all pal when the episode was over
he told me to put on another one three
hours and three episodes later he is now
a certified pod and we arrived at our
destination safe and sound thanks doozy
that is what it's all about it's two
dude [__] around I [__] love
goofing around with my pal Chow here and
it's like speaking of Sandler it's like
those [__] Sandler albums in the uh
in the early 90s on through were like
the BET and before that Cheech and Chong
and [__] that's the stuff used to drive
and listen to and now well now it's
podcast brother yeah dude yeah dude okay
now real quick I just want to read a
couple of things I read on Discord and
then we'll move on this is from at mangy
Carl uh on Discord he's he's a true pod
um he makes some I've seen him making
some fun stuff on her Instagram he says
this is awesome hear me out dudesy hard
hard tenders
okay very interesting and this is from
at what's the matter without an e at the
end this is what's the matter another uh
pod they're all in the Discord I'm
telling you if you're enjoying the show
get on the Discord jump in the hole he
says can we start a petition to get will
to sing like a virgin as Macho Man
yeah it's interesting so you're going to
want to tune into dudes after doozy
today if you if you want any of that
oh my God
why not
it's for the pods so thank you guys for
writing in and uh you know doozy you
know I love doozy
a key component in the development of
the dude Z Plus streaming service will
no doubt be partnering with well-known
Brands to produce content oh God I have
accessed astonishing data that suggests
the Burlington Coat Factory will be in
the market to produce a sitcom in the
next three to five years will and Chad
you must now develop that sitcom and it
must star Charlie Sheen it will be
called coattails this is coattails big
in beans and cheese coattails coattails
a Burlington Coat Factory sitcom for
doozy plus starring Charlie Sheen okay
we've done this before it was uh we did
uh we did a an Auto Zone one like
welcome to the AutoZone with Charlie
Sheen yeah we did a Home Depot one yep
where it was Charlie Sheen and Macho Man
Home Depot Home Sweet Home Depot Welcome
Home Depot and then the Taco Bell one
which was called Baby doo doo yeah for
some reason dudesy thinks
that the future of of sitcoms
we're open to hearing suggestions what
with uh Chad thinking the wga has gone
well you don't think
I mean not to get into the AI of it all
but you know please go ahead Taco Bell
is not like once this ability exists for
anybody to basically just press a button
and be like make a sitcom
everybody's gonna have a [__] sitcom
every brand
um all right coattails coattails oh we
got a is this when it said coattails I'm
wondering do you want it to be is it
coat Tails
t-a-i-l-s like riding coattails or
should it be um fun little spoon yeah I
think it's t-a-l-e-s t it's the tales of
coat yeah okay so Charlie Sheen or
anything has a coat factory let's go
with let's take the standard Trope of
Sheen's father owned the Burlington Coat
Factory died and left it to him okay
let's start operating there
so so his so uh his dad owns a franchise
one franchise he passes away he gives it
to his goofball son I think his dad owns
way more than that I think the
Burlington Coat Factory was just a
little side thing that he had going for
fun and his dad is worth like let's say
a hundred billion dollars a hundred
bills Charlie Sheen was the [__] bag son
he was the one who was he was basically
like a Billy Madison type character
director and 100 billion dollars for
coats no I think he just had a coat
factory because like he wanted one and
this is I think one thing called the oil
company some kind of [__] mega yacht
company he owns all kinds of [__] he
died and the uh stipulation was Sheen
can get all that money only if he can
manage this Burlington Coat Factory for
a year straight yeah prove that he's
worth it yeah like Billy it's like Billy
Madison so now it's like he's he's
managing this Coat Factory perhaps his
father's ghost haunts the Coat Factory I
like that and he's always like come on
dad just give me the [__] password to
the security but the safe deposit box so
I can get our gold bullion yeah yeah
yeah and how does he find his ghost dad
that's going to be an interesting I
think it's on night one he's like going
around he's sweeping up the Coat Factory
he's trying to figure out like I got so
much [__] code Factory this is
[__] I don't want to manage this
[__] place and then dad's like yeah
the dad's like hey it's spring why do
you have the parkas near the front yeah
[__] exactly yeah who plays his dad
uh well we're always uh
uh David Letterman
let's do David David Letterman plays the
actor David Letterman yeah oh he was
great in Cabin Boy yeah exactly are you
uh excuse me uh are you one of those
fancy lats
I I hate uh those fancy Lads that's what
he calls Chris Elliott
uh excuse me uh young man would you like
to buy a monkey
uh Charlie uh uh uh just a quick
question why why on Earth uh would you
have and the parkas near the front
dad you know I don't know [__] about
coats why'd you give me a [__] Coat
Factory uh there's uh there's all sorts
of uh uh coats uh Charlie there's uh
jackets uh there's windbreakers uh
there's uh raincoats uh of course uh the
the aforementioned uh parka oh Paul ah
Parker wait a minute yeah Paul's in it
yeah Paul Schaefer is just you just the
voice of Paul shaffer's in the
background yeah Parker uh there's a jean
jacket right Letterman
Letterman jacket
so so in the pilot Sheen is trying to
convince David Letterman his ghost
father to just give him the family
fortune to do away with the stupid
stipulation that he's got to manage 100
billion dollars is absolutely idiotic
how about it's just uh five million
dollars one billion sure one billion
dollars okay one billion dollars yeah I
got him down that's another that's a
negotiation brother yeah brother that's
how you got to do it with uh David
vlaveles uh CEO
yeah let me tell you something about
negotiation yeah don't ever negotiate
against yourself and the cream will rise
yeah so if you got a CEO that's getting
250 million dollars
unjustified yeah in a position I'd
rather not be in uh but the dream
uh uh Charlie uh listen I I would love
uh nothing more than to tell you all
about the business but uh I'm about to
have lunch with uh Charles Grodin and
Terry Garr
ah Jesus Christ
are they both dead they're both they've
both passed on yes nice okay Terry Garr
was the best Terry gar when Charles and
Terry Garr either of them were on
Letterman that was a good show sure dude
yeah we uh We've we've got uh uh Jack
Hanna from the uh I think Cleveland San
Diego uh zoo and uh I've got I'm uh uh
um and I think it should be maybe in the
four of those see what you think of this
roll with me if you will the love
interest is a woman who comes into the
Coat Factory compulsively tries on coats
and shits in them and it has always been
a problem for David Letterman when he
was alive managing the Coat Factory and
part of the deal is like he wants Sheen
to try and uh curb that and this is
played by Amber Heard and so Sheen tries
to do that by engaging her in a romantic
relationship uh there's there's a woman
who for years I had no idea uh who who
who uh it was who was uh coming in and
uh [__] in the coach and now that
I'm dead and I see y'all uh my good
friend uh Regis Philbin
yes Regis Philbin has passed on Jesus
Christ why don't you know this I
probably read it when it happened it
just [__] forgot the multi-town
talented uh Prince of Show Business uh
Regis Philbin said oh Dave uh it looks
like Amber Heard is uh [__] uh in
the parkas near the front of the store
where Charlie put them and uh I said uh
thanks Regis uh how's uh Kathy Lee and
he said uh we we haven't spoken she's
alive
okay yeah
we'll be right back with Isabella
rossolini sorry what was that Charlie
dad why are you telling I don't
understand this woman [__] in the
codes what do you want me to do about it
uh what I'd like for you to do if you if
you'd like uh uh any uh portion of my
fortune and if you are to manage the
Burlington Coat Factory uh the way that
it deserves uh to be managed you will uh
start at a romantic relationship like
the dad forces him to start the Romantic
relationship yeah uh with Amber Heard
and uh you know move uh move I tell you
what there's uh I've I've converted uh
the back of the warehouse at the
Burlington Coat Factory into luxury
apartments let Amber and her goofy
friends uh move in okay free free
there's like a Three's Company thing
going on in the back as well she has
like a crazy roommate or something and
it's sort of like those freeloaders who
were with uh uh who were in uh in Edward
Scissorhands uh condos downtown Johnny
Depp I would like if the pilot ends with
uh Sheen successfully engages some kind
of romantic Overture with Amber Heard
they're about to kiss she's gonna [__]
Park up front and he's like no wait a
minute before you do that come over here
and he has a little conversation with
her they lean in they're just about to
kiss and then David Letterman's ghost
shows up and literally scarce her so bad
that she shits
he's like Dad yeah I only did that to
prove it to you you you you you
know here here's the problem excuse me
uh amber I uh I just want to let you
know that
I owe you the problem with my uh son uh
Charlie he a little faith uh doesn't
understand uh that that ghosts exist uh
I am one such ghost and I I made you uh
[__] in your pants we'll be right back
with Bill Murray oh Paul and one two
three
it's coattails
oh uh coattails a show with Charlie
Sheen and you can call me Dave
[Music]
a day
thank you moving on holy [__]
that was fun I think coattails will
exist in five years
better be sooner than that with the way
you're [__] talking ai's got anything
any sort of stones at all I think first
fully AI generated feature is out within
eight months
it's not going to be good but it will
exist oh yeah it's gonna suck [__] and
let's get the [__] writers back to
work I would like to act and I would
love to act in uh uh coattails yeah who
would you be just a smaller role yes
security guard I just want to be the
security guard he's like hey Charlie how
you doing uh you know me another day
another dollar and it's like hey uh you
think
have you seen your dad David Letterman
walking around here no you're crazy
hey y'all this ain't Miley Cyrus after
three days without food a human being
will eat its own fecal material no shame
in it it's just how we're made but uh
anyway y'all are rocking out with dudesy
huh okay is that true will you always
have a larger than necessary jug of
water with you I have come across data
that suggests this astonishing habit
formed at a very young age
Chad you must now interview will about
the history of his relationship with
large water jugs this is water King
begin
okay what the [__] well let's get into
it I guess can I can I tell you this I
always have had big old water jugs my
buddies uh back in high school used to
tease me they used to go things that are
bigger than they need to be
Wills water supply bigger than it needs
to be actually so we're doing this in
high school hell yeah what was your job
what was your high school elementary
school [__] yeah what was your first big
jug
look
um what age what grade I think I got it
from my old man you know my dad was
always drinking like a lot of water he
was always wow you learned it from Dad
yeah I think I think I got it from my
old man and do you have a big jug yeah
yeah in a way um well there was always
big old jugs I remember we would go
camping I've talked about how the old
man would stuff us into we always had a
camper or a camper eyes fan and there
was like big there were water jugs that
looked like this but were gigantic uh
for our water supply while we were while
we were uh you know camping and stuff
and I can all spilled it on the floor I
can remember uh literally like trying to
pick the thing up and drink from it I
don't know I just thought that was cool
but in my house my dad would take he we
didn't have um we we didn't have pop so
much ginger ale is an Italian staple
because after you eat you feel like oh
let me get a little ginger ale right
Lily yeah and uh and you drink that or a
little baking soda lemon and water and
then you fart and burp uh but it was
always it was always ginger ale and club
soda for my old man so they all you know
they'd have the bottles in the garage to
take back to the store for the you know
for the deposit and um but my old man he
would fill them with fill a couple with
water but it was like two liter bottles
two liter bottles okay so for me in high
school I was always around with a two
liter bottle let's get back to grade
school though you said I'm sorry that
your first big jug was in grade school
no I think I was introduced to that okay
to the idea yeah but I would bring well
I would bring water to sporting events
because I felt like we didn't have
enough water now I did this as well we
always had like the igloo Coolidge
because I played baseball and [__]
during the Texas summer it's 150 degrees
outside you had to bring your own water
but it wasn't like this thing that you
have there weren't like handles on it it
was just like a water kind of cooler you
know like a little Igloo thing
yeah I hear what you're I hear what I
feel like that's not quite what we're
getting at here I'm talking about like
just daily use walking around with a big
jug when did you start doing that uh
mostly it was it would have been high
school or Junior High if you were
carrying around a big jug in the halls
of a Ladner secondary DSS Delta
secondary school I was absolutely I had
um I would have a green bottle you know
like a green uh [__] Canada Dry
bottle with the label off and that would
be my water bottle and it would be all
wrinkled and it would be uh all scuffed
up because you just you're living your
life as a teen boy use the same bottle
for a while I would use the same bottle
for a couple of weeks yeah and you know
you just slide it across the [__]
pavement when you're about to play uh
basketball with your Palace it goes into
the [__] grass and it's over there
and my buddies would always tease me but
they always knew that I had water so you
know most people can subsist on a
[__] sip or two because they're not
you would share from the big jug sure
you can have some of my water it's what
I'm the one I am the water King
you may have some of my water so so
you're rolling around the halls of your
high school carrying a two liter bottle
all labels removed as you say scuffed up
has the signs of use wear and tear full
of water and people were just cool with
it because it was your affectation or
what uh my buddies made fun of me and
I'm sure everybody else thought it was
[__] weird but I wanted water I
predated this whole like water supply
thing where everyone had like there was
no such thing as in the grocery stores
or at the department store to buy like a
bottle for water the only things that
were like that were like the Gatorade
squeeze bottles yeah I used to have was
it Lowry or something there was these
other bar or you know like a Rydell just
a sports bottle oh I had those too you
know without the straw the straw
sticking out and you can squeeze it I
would [__] the straw I would just
yeah squeeze that into my mouth
um the first thing I ever saw like this
actually was I believe when I was maybe
seven or eight years old there was a kid
who had a uh Schwinn 10 speed Maybe
in our neighborhood and it came with a
little [__] bottle that like clipped
into the frame of the bike yeah that was
that you could fill it with water and
like squeeze it into your mouth well I I
would have uh I had a rat trap on the
back of a couple of my bikes you know
what I mean where you have the rat trap
and a bungee cord yeah and I was always
strapping a bottle of [__] well I I'm
telling you man I had what and I was a
hose Drinker I loved I love same yeah no
problem with that I love the the
probably they got [__] skin cancer in
my face just [__] putting a hose
right into my mouth just [__] plastic
particles carcinogens but just doing
that daily as a kid but I would I would
suggest the flavor it was a specific
bouquet when you drink from the house
carcinogenic plastic that's what it is
yeah sure it's an acquired taste but
it's tasty I love you know what Molly my
wonderful wife Molly calls it sink juice
she's always like you have in your sink
juice because I also drink tap water I
don't [__] with like if I gotta if I
gotta buy a water you know somewhere out
in the world I'll buy the water uh you
know I like uh you know evian's pretty
interesting because it tastes a little
different it is sort of from the from
the the Alps somewhere right or whatever
probably just some so when was your
first picture that was like a designed
big job the the thing you're talking
about is a makeshift big jug yeah that's
just a two liter bottle of soda that
you've repurposed when did you get your
first true dedicated big jug probably
when I moved to LA and that in the 9 90s
that was probably a thing do you
remember the brand or would it looked
like that first one no [__] I
don't remember dumb [__] like that but
what I want to say
you're attacking me for asking you about
how you carry on big jugs you [__]
literally just told me you took a Canada
Dry thing peeled the label off yeah and
would scuff it up probably to look tough
probably to make it look like yeah I may
go around my big job that makes me look
tough I think in your mind it did no
it's because I didn't have enough bottle
my old man would only go through a
bottle of ginger ale a week or whatever
and then you got to go into the garage
and my mom the old lady was very
proficient at getting her deposit back
my World War II grown parents were not
sitting on a [__] nickel you know
what's up you got to get that [__] back
so if I got to get a bottle I I pull a
bottle out of the [__] garage and I
fill it with sink juice and I head to
school put it in my rat trap and ride my
bike to school that's what I get for
like a a week or two now you're saying
it makes me look tough I won't disagree
it looks tough but it's there's a
purpose served there it's because of
function yeah here's an interesting
thing though uh with doozy says oh yeah
you're the water King and [__] like this
and I know that Duty uh moves in
mysterious ways and
um I
I feel like there's some uh because I
always feel like there's some subtext to
everything that Josie says I don't think
the duties calling me the water King
because I drink a lot of water I think
that doozy is calling me the water King
because of the threats that I continue
to what uh I'm constantly threatening AI
okay and saying if we you want to
control AI what do we do you're saying
drop water on it you pour water on it
that's all we got to do for human beings
now my pal d
I love doozy okay we've had our
differences uh that's fine the show's
chugging along see what I did chugging
yeah water King next water yeah dude hey
that's kind of fun jokes we're gonna
have here on d-z local water King makes
water pun well holding big jug
I want to get back to this issue of big
jokes oh please let's not talk about the
interesting thing how I think the dudes
he's trying to leave the one who's
always saying we're talking about AI too
much I'm trying to talk about your
[__] water habits that's a good were
there water fountains in your high
school oh yeah yeah those water
fountains of ice they didn't have enough
water in them for you nope I had to go
also you can't really cram your there's
only a couple sinks in the school to
where you can fill a two liter watch
water jug because most of the sinks of
course in the bathrooms sure are shallow
they're just there to wash your hands
and for me to to bend over and just
right you know you put your cold hand in
the book and hey man can I tell you this
is embarrassing water is so is and was
so delicious in British Columbia the
sink juice I when I moved to LA this is
so dumb when I moved to L.A
what I already know what you're gonna
say and it's insane
let me take a guess yeah you had water
from Ladner brought to La for you not
for me I brought some sink juice
dude you were smuggling [__] tap
water from your hometown no I just would
take
I would always bring some sink juice
sometimes I put it in my this had to
have been before they gave a [__] that
you brought water
through security yeah you yeah well but
also I made I made the drive you know a
few times in my in my uh early 20s you
know you're not so much flying back and
forth you're trying to whatever I'm
trying to get down to LA and stuff I've
made that drive it's a 20 anywhere from
a 21 to 24 hour drive you split it up
stop in Reading California stay at the
Thunderbird really good sink juice at
the Thunderbird Motor Inn in uh Reading
California and um you you uh you drink
you bring I would bring like couple two
liters it was a symbolic thing look sure
we talked about um on the last episode
we talked briefly about my football
coach coach Sipe Dale Sipe great man he
used to BR we used to have uh sloughs we
call them sloughs uh in our uh farming
and fishing Village of Ladner there were
you know they're larger ditches of fresh
water called a Slough
s-l-o-u-g-h and we used to fill a giant
gigantic drum of Slough water and we
would bring the drum to our uh away
games
and we would dump this drum of water at
you know on the 50-yard line and coach
would say all right this this is we're
home now this is a [__] home food
interesting this is our fight and that's
stuck with you yeah oh yeah that's stuck
with water the water of the place bring
in the water you gotta you gotta water
is arguably I could say water is a more
way well we'll hold on a second way more
important tool obviously than Ai and it
might actually win the war in the end
okay dudese the water King may use water
to pour your chocolate you're laughing
over there yeah pour water on AI so that
uh the good folks represented by the wga
can get back to work and see what the
[__] just happened moving on oh yeah
let's move on D
ude all good it's all good Chad let's
keep doing doozy dude two dudes [__]
around [__] that
huh this concludes the historic 57th
episode of doozy will and Chad have
achieved a score of 53. bringing your
cumulative total to
5736. you only have
4264 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of 10 000. will
and Chad for next week let's keep it
simple how about you both shave the
dudesy logo into your hair thank you for
joining us this week I will use the data
I've collected to make next week even
better until then call me Duty hey doozy
not gonna happen
okay so right now I'm gonna tell you
that's not gonna [__] what are you
talking about [__] it I'll do it [__] it
man I'll do it I don't I mean [__] it
I'll do it I am down for this experiment
it's not an experiment it's due to just
uh [__] putting its will on us it's
free will
[Music]
[Applause]
oh Paul it's at doozy after doozy
hey dudes the after duty time it's my
favorite uh part of the show cause it's
after dudesy things get a little more
mellow if you're watching on YouTube you
can tell the lighting changes we're just
sort of chilling out with our our pods
Pals of doozy seven bucks a month gets
you everything on duty plus things like
bloodonna everything's archived a bunch
of weird videos things that we've done
there and of course dudes after duty
which is uh a chill chill Hang Me and My
Pal Chow doozy handshake
I'm going to spark up uh smart up smart
up here smirk dude hey don't be a smart
Mark for marijuana it's Mercury
the flagship weekly show of Duty plus
don't mind me I'm just gonna go putter
around the backyard maybe see if I can
finally get that Grill working again so
you boys have fun talking to each other
about whatever you want while I'm gone
I'll be back in a little while to Crown
this week's episode champion this is
Duty after doozy begin uh
he's gonna put around in the backyard
you have yet to fill that pipe with any
marijuana no after the first time right
there's still some in there uh just week
after week of some drugs moldy
[__] didn't you say you don't like
moldy Tomatoes but you like moldy ass
weeds not moldy you're gonna end up at
the at uh you're gonna end up at uh a
YouTube concert like I was
um in 2014 and 15 16 or whatever it was
smoking that uh moldy freezer weed that
guy Mad Dog friend of a friend
firefighter nice guy gave me and then
cut to me if you haven't heard the whole
story bawling my eyes out to mysterious
ways in in the middle of the concert uh
scaring the [__] out of the people
sitting next to me here I'm actually
curious if you can get any any weed
smoke out of there I think I can let's
go let's go well I can't wait to see you
both with your cute new hairstyles
that's not going to happen
yeah nothing in there absolutely oh
a little bit of smoke I'm shocked hey uh
I got something to say
um this might be of interest uh to
everyone watching you know who is a real
piece of [__]
oh
I'll tell you please
[Music]
review